all right hey everybody it has been
an insane insane day not the least of
which
uh is because we have a vice
presidential nominee for joe
biden at this point which i'm going to
talk about and i've already been
tweeting about
we also are standing by for a donald
trump press briefing at the bottom of
the hour
we have clips and memes and all sorts of
different things to look at and on top
of it
i'm in the as many of you know for this
week i'm broadcasting from the bunker
as i'm calling it and had some
electrical issues today
where i actually this stream may end
prematurely because
i don't want to get into deep deep
electrical stuff
but in short if i have my laptop plugged
in
in addition to the other equipment it
creates an
arc fault and we're bringing in a very
powerful
electrician hopefully tomorrow morning
to
deal with some of that because um
arc faults are very ugly so basically i
will be able to stream
for the duration of my laptop battery
and i know that that's you know a very
very scary thing for a lot of people so
we are standing by for donald trump
monitoring
other streams other than the white house
stream i would love to see as usual
what's going on in the room it doesn't
yet
seem as though fox news has a live
stream going not that i am seeing anyway
oh wait here it is oh no live kamala is
chosen that's not it no
um okay well we'll keep an eye on that
and if anybody at any point can tell me
uh where we are live
then i am glad to take a look at that if
you're just
joining us um where to even start i
guess
we should start with kamala harris right
because kamala harris
has been selected as joe biden's
running mate and i might you know this
news is
how old is this news 15 minutes old
roughly
uh my perspective right now i
mostly outlined in a tweet thread
we can just go through it initial
reaction to kamala harris as biden's vp
pick who for weeks now i've been saying
publicly is the
most likely pick hello i'm not patting
myself on the back it's just it's the
way you know it felt like the energy
went away
from elizabeth warren and it didn't seem
to me
that joe biden was going to go someone
will go with someone
with lower name recognition so that's
how i
ended up uh with with um harris
second part her biggest obvious downside
is her role in prosecuting the war on
drugs
oh boy that's that's sad while
a.g of california trump will hit her on
this saying
he signed the first step act commuted
unfair
drug sentences etc while biden goes and
picks
cop mullah we 100 that's going to happen
it may even happen
uh in today's um uh press briefing
with donald trump obvious upside is
harris's age she's 55 relative to trump
and biden being upper 70s and mike pence
being a 60 plus white guy not very
interesting that's the identity sort of
analysis and then we will talk about
her being of course the first black
woman as a vp or presidential nominee
another upside is that kamala will
absolutely destroy mike pence and
debates now i want to be really clear
when i say this i don't mean that
republicans will think that she won
right these trumpists are committed to
the idea that
trump and pence can do no wrong but for
thinking people
rhetorically harris is uh formidable
and then lastly if biden harris win and
this is a big deal
gavin newsom of course the governor of
california picks a temporary senator
from california who will be a democrat
had elizabeth warren been the nominee
our republican governor charlie baker
would have picked a republican senator
to replace her until a special election
when we you know we're looking at
whether
democrats can wrestle control of the
senate from republicans in the fall
if you in addition imagine that it ends
up 50 50 or even
uh yeah 50 50 with biden as the
tiebreaker
uh or it would be harris as the
tiebreaker effectively
and then charlie baker says no no no not
so fast
uh or sorry if it was warren as the
tiebreaker i think you know what i mean
then charlie baker puts in a republican
and it's 51-49 again so i don't uh
that that is a very specific strategic
reason why
um i think harris is better than warren
but on politics
warren was the most progressive person
um
of the top tier folks being considered
so that's my thread on kamala
which you can find on my twitter page by
the way not that you guys care but i i
really like this
um my most successful tweet ever
is now at nearly 110 000 likes i'm not
really like good on twitter
so to speak so this was great and it was
retweeted by patton oswalt and
um uh hugh laurie the actor and a whole
bunch of great people so
very very exciting stuff um looks like
people are already getting the ban
hammer dropped on them
on youtube which is of course very very
exciting twitch seems pretty calm so far
oh although we do actually we're almost
already at a level three hype train over
on twitch which is
fantastic i have some super chats coming
in let's look at a couple of them
a retro pathek says kamala means orange
in india keep leadership orange
okay remy lebro says did the republicans
ever intend to pass more pandemic relief
or was the plan
always to have trump seem like a savior
while they get to
while they keep get to work rhetoric
um i think that there was a sincere
hope belief among republicans a couple
of months ago
that they wouldn't need a second
stimulus because the virus would get
better
and of course that hasn't happened
zachary foster says david there have
been some
theories that the gamalia institute
vaccine by russia
is the uh is just the oxford vaccine
based on
data that they stole that's listen
i don't really i'm not taking a position
yet on the russian vaccine
the russian vaccine is out um reportedly
did i read correctly that putin putin's
daughter got the vaccine
listen i'm not taking a position on that
vaccine yet i have no particular insight
into it
uh and i'm gonna wait to hear from
doctors about that
um unknown prodigy says you are going to
crush sam cedar for very banal reasons
or i say banal myself but you are much
better looking than sam wow that's
interesting i actually have a meme
related to that
let me show you guys a little something
you you might find this interesting or
you might not let me take a look
just gotta pull this up and see how i
can get it on screen
check somebody sent this to me now this
is not real okay
this is from sam cedar sinking to a new
low and hosting msnbc the other day
breaking news pacman calls cedar a joke
are bots behind inflated youtube success
this is really really ugly stuff i was
hoping that things were not going to get
this ugly in the race to a million
between me and sam
but it's possible i mean listen i don't
want to speak for sam but it's possible
he sees himself as being up on the ropes
i am
up to 933 000 youtube subscribers
so he he may be upset
he may be upset and he may be resorting
to these kind of click baity
gotcha journalism type segments
uh and if that's the case i feel bad for
him i really do
um okay what else do we have going on
here
oh somebody made this uh let's see if
you guys like this this be interesting
let me put this up here uh let me get it
sized
properly for us uh is this right
yeah there we go somebody made this from
yesterday's stream revealed
just the news
[Music]
including too many dead people
okay that's pretty good right i think
that that's pretty good i'm only even
gonna play that once because sometimes
people want the um some people want the
repeat
but sometimes i think it's better to do
less leave people wanting more i think
that that one's really really good
people do like that one okay yeah i
think that one's fantastic that's one of
the better memes
that we've gotten keeping an eye
on other streams anybody know of another
stream of today's press briefing that
maybe is live in the room
fox news is not the white house feed is
often slow to go live
um grandmaster benjamin feingold is
gifting subscriptions can you imagine
that is actually ben's first
gifted sub in the channel uh
amazing i already did comment on biden
choosing
kamala yes i did um if anybody is live
in the room
just let me know and i will switch over
to
that stream um okay
other things here's something else i'm
looking at and i want to
we need a plan okay we i don't know what
the plan is
i'm i wish i could bring a solution but
i'm really only bringing a question
um at the end of october in fact
here's the date on october 29th
at 8 30 in the morning that's five days
before the election
there will be an estimate of q3 gdp
okay now we already know
how this is going to go the garbage math
you are going to be hit with the garbage
garbage math very powerfully and the way
it's going to go
is um we lost
like 32 35 gdp
in q2 so if you start at 100 and you
lose
call it 30 you're down to 70.
it's quite plausible that we will
gain 20 these are annualized numbers
which is a whole other level but forget
about that
if you go if you're at 70 and you gain
20
20 of 70 is 14 that puts you back at 84.
guaranteed five days before the
presidential election
donald trump is going to come out and
say i have brought us
the biggest single quarter gdp growth in
the history of the united states
and technically it's going to be true
of course we will still be far below
where we were before
the virus and a lot of this will have
had nothing to do with donald trump
anyway right so could this actually
give the election to donald trump i've
said before we need to be very very
careful about polls that say by the way
polls like these
which say biden is up 10 one came out
today
biden is up 13. etc we need to be very
careful about these you know plus 10
with a margin of error of three and a
half means
biden might only be up by three this is
a registered voter model
uh likely voter models tend to be
considered more accurate i don't know
anything about gu politics and biden
plus 13 but my point is
if on october 29th
gdp goes plus 20 and trump takes credit
that's a five-day period during which
you really might be able to swing one or
two points in your direction
next thing you know donald trump has
been re-elected to presidency of the
united states so
that's going to happen we need to figure
out in advance how to deal with that
propaganda
i hope democrats are thinking about how
to deal with that inevitable
inevitable propaganda but i don't know
exactly
what uh what what the answer is a few
other super chats are coming in
um let's see here eggnogs wants to know
if i play
wow or any games not really i'm training
for
pog champs 2 which is a chess tournament
but otherwise i don't really uh i don't
really play
too many games um other super chats
coming in
philhatio clever you ever considered
getting on trt
to increase muscle mass you're looking
frail pale and
female i worry about you if physically
confronted by a trumpist my god
i hope that was worth five dollars for
you really i do i wish you the best
man that's a weird weird message uh
let's see what else we've got here super
chats
alex walker says why harris over rice
harris's campaign was a dud and she has
a lot of baggage
why not pick someone who's known things
we currently need like repairing global
relations or economic expertise
i mean listen if if susan rice had been
the pick
it would have been all about benghazi
all over again um
so any anybody would have had some
issues if it were warren it would have
been elitist northeast senator
although she certainly would have been
the most progressive i think that
there's always
always a problem uh we are in the middle
of a level five
hype train on twitch and rapidly
approaching uh 100
let me say a few thank yous there uh
urged
hardcore says you're a legend david
ignore
ronald reagan rd killa has thrown us
uh twitch prime subscription my way
morbus
mia and pizzaface turbo virgin
handsy german
uh spudnik19 is in the action
neon a lot of people a lot of people
doing a lot of things
in twitch chat which is always
always exciting um i do have
oh wait a second oh okay no hold on i
don't want to fall behind on memberships
let me say thank you to christopher
sharp who is new member number one
at joinedpakman.com and
oh that's depressing it's only
christopher i don't have anybody else to
thank
that's tragic all right well we can we
can get back to that
people asking about stacey abrams i
don't believe stacey abrams was ever
really a contender
i think that she was not experienced
enough yes for people wondering
kamala harris is joe biden's running
mate
we're keeping an eye out for other live
streams let's see if now this
now this live
nope not seeing that who else might be
live
uh the hill live trump
22 23 hours ago now it looks like the
only feed we have right now is the white
house feed that's that's sad
again if somebody can communicate to me
what feed might be live it is scheduled
to start just three minutes from now
uh yes yes if you are here for a stream
it is scheduled to start
at the bottom of the hour just three
minutes from now
see if anybody knows no i'm not seeing
anybody direct me to any particular live
stream
yeah i know he's never on time but
okay yeah uh i see people posting links
but those are not allowed in the chat
you can just describe it
i'm not gonna go to right side
broadcasting that's a little bit crazy
um
okay well i guess we'll just wait and
see what happens with this stream
not the end of the world a couple of
clips from the last few days
oh c-span but it's the my question is
whether c-span is live in the room
let's see c-span live
c-span i'm not actually
seeing that c-span is live
23 hours ago uploads
older stuff
yeah i'm not seeing it okay bloomberg
bloomberg trump live let's see what
we've got
global financial news news conference
very nice all right let's see if we've
got live in the room that could be great
uh here we go perfect okay this is oh
new signs they've got like green
social distancing signs now in the room
very good okay now that we've got that
out of the way let me i'll do a couple
other super chats
and robin neal says i joined when you
were off air
so add me to your new subscriptions
today lol dave you are awesome
okay let's i'm willing to do that let's
see if i can find that
uh where is robin
hmm not actually
seeing robin anywhere
unable to verify ryan susan
melissa i i apologize i'm not able to
find robin how crazy is that
i do want to say thanks to theo
havercroft
theo has just signed up and his new
member number two
um joshua haft
is new member number three on my website
and that's it okay a couple videos
people sent me things people clipped
from recent streams always love to hear
from you guys and seeing
so this is a little bit of like
streamception this is me yesterday
talking about stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell the second i just call him kenny
two
like for the second kenny two that's
what i'm calling him now it's shorter
um this is me talking about him talking
about my chess coach
alexandra botez take a list people seem
to like this for some reason
chess coaches alexandra botes
you tell me what you make of this this
seems like there's a little bit of i
don't know if we would call it
jealousy or envy but something seems a
little weird take a look at this
right hey listen i hope you have fun i
hope you have fun with your new best
friend david pakman playing in pogchamps
okay i hope you guys uh
have a great time over there and i'll
just be over getting dumped by my fiance
you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's pretty
aggressive
um i didn't like i i don't like how
destiny
he seems rattled and on tilt quite
frankly by the fact that alexander has
been coaching me
it's weird it's weird and i'm gonna have
to probably get a hold of him and see if
we can clear some of that up because
that's a very
i don't want things going in that
direction with stephen right
and you know i just think we have to be
very very careful there
you know a lot of times when i'm just
going to turn a light on here hold on
there we go it's a little better um i i
find myself agreeing with a lot of the
things i've previously said on stream
here's one other one that people like
this is older i don't even really get
this but let's take a look at it
sheepy roman says the kardashians are
lying to you i don't even know what
they're saying
matthias veloso poopoo [ __ ] browned out
in this debate pepe laugh i don't is
that french i don't know what language
that person's speaking
that's a classic david paquin show
moment don't forget it my friends that
is a
instant classic david pakman show moment
um
hard to imagine a better moment than
that right i know you guys know it
you know what i'm talking about uh okay
other super chat's coming in
alex arvinitis asks whether i've heard
of spotted lanternflies that they're an
invasive species spreading all over the
northeast
and that they're threatening crops i
have not heard of that
uh carissa gates wants to hear my
thoughts on kamala
that's at the beginning of the stream
and i also have a twitter
thread whoop not that that's weird it
wasn't that
i also have a twitter thread my most
recent post
which is a sort of um outline of my
current thoughts about
kamala let's see what else
we've got here daniel benilla
benia or as we say in argentina bonita
says have you thought how trump's
inaugural speech could be read by biden
and it would make perfect sense it's
like he projected his presidency
you know i haven't thought about that uh
daniel also says 1 million
subs yeah i see people calling for an
update from the standpoint of a million
let me find that for you guys i do have
an updated projection
we are ready to make a projection sort
of like cnn on election night
um so let me give you the backstory on
this when we reached 900
000 subscribers two weeks ago the
projection from socialblade was that we
would hit a million on january 9th
and that started to creep up january 8
january 6
it then got pulled into um 2020
it was like gonna be december 30th
december 25 could have been a christmas
miracle for a jew like me
and it's been getting pulled pulled
pulled and we are now scheduled to hit a
million
subscribers on youtube on november 26th
meaning we are 23 days
if we can move it up 23 days with
continued acceleration
um we will hit a million subscribers
by election day um so that's
very exciting very very exciting and
something i mean listen
i know maybe a lot of y'all don't care
but i'm very much looking forward to it
it would be a huge milestone for the
show
um luke visinoni
says david you are hilarious man i'm not
even sure you mean to be but you crack
me up with your deadpan responses to
people's dumb comments thank you
what else do we have here a lot of super
chats
tristan mccoppen says please don't stop
setting up clips by talking before it
acts as a vaccine against donald trump
republican gaslighting and spin
yeah you know something interesting
happened i got a few emails from people
saying david
when you play clips on your you know the
clips you upload in your podcast
you're doing too much setup in other
words you're talking too much
before you play the clip about what we
are going to see
and you are tainting right people
concerned about concerned about a taint
you're tainting my view
figuring out what is in the clip so
today in the clip we published earlier
i did very little introduction i
basically played the clip and then did
the analysis
and i got a ton of emails from people
saying i don't like it david please go
back to the way you do it where you
actually set it up
um and it serves again as uh as tristan
is suggesting maybe is a sort of
inoculation uh for lack of a better term
which i think it's an idea
i think it's definitely an idea jala
hippo
has sent a twitch prime subscription and
says where is that compilation video
someone made of your twitch moments
from a few months back i remember one
clip was you making a female streamer's
heart rate go up
oh i wish i could find that if somebody
can find that and tell me how to find it
i would love to uh i think it's called
like david pakman boomer something about
boomer
let me see if i can find it
uh let's see here david pakman
favorite boomer maybe it was the most
likable boomer on twitch yeah here it is
this is the video people are referring
to
it is pretty funny i think there's at
least a few funny elements
premiere
people are saying trump is actually on
oh my god these
states and cities have an absolute duty
to use all resources necessary to end
the violence
and all of the injury and death let me
actually go over to a better more
powerful stream here we go
and uh the law enforcement and the new
york's finest are as good as it gets
and they should be allowed to do their
job if they do their job if they're
allowed to do their job
the new york city problem will be solved
and be solved quickly
they do it well the mayor bill de blasio
should immediately hire back
all of the police who were fired
without justification they were fired
i guess that's part of defund the police
by the democrats they should hire new
york city's finest back you have some
incredible
policemen doing specific jobs that
nobody else can do
actually when it comes to terrorism and
other things
together the city of chicago and the
state of illinois have
25 000 police officers sheriffs and
guardsmen available to quell any
violence they can do it very quickly
very easily if allowed to do their jobs
again
if allowed to do their jobs our police
our law enforcement is incredible but
they have to be allowed to do their jobs
the democrats or the radical left
democrats or both because they're
becoming one of the same if you look at
election results
the democrats are being taken over by
the radical left the city of portland
and the so this is a new strategy now
everything's so radical on the on the
democratic party
state of oregon have ten thousand fine
officers and guardsmen available
seattle washington and washington state
have ten thousand available so seattle
city of seattle
and washington state itself they have
great people they have to be allowed to
do their job i'm urging them to
deploy these resources to protect their
citizens and to stop the violence
and all of the things that we watch on
television going on although
a lot of the unfortunately fake news
don't like to put it on
because it shows that the democrats are
doing a very bad job of law enforcement
they have to put it on
you have to be honest with the people of
this country
notice by the way that when there's
violence and trump is president it's the
fault of democrat mayors
but if biden is president it will be
biden's fault that there will be
violence in cities not the mayors oh
weird
i'm offering all available federal
support requested to stop the violence
and arrest the criminals we have to be
asked by the governors or the mayors it
will be their very
rapidly it's ready willing and able
we're all ready willing and able to go
to these jurisdictions and take care of
them very quickly
you saw what happened in minneapolis
they ripped the city apart
when the national guard went in
it ended immediately it was immediate
and lasted these acts of destruction are
not isolated incidents but demonstrate
the
pattern of violent left-wing extremism
that you get to see if you're watching
the right
news program slurring under any rational
definition the arson attack on
the police precinct in portland would be
considered an act of left-wing domestic
terrorism
they really are anarchists these are
left-wing anarchists
they are anarchists directing the
department of justice
really struggling with that slur i hope
you guys noticed to
stop these anarchists immediately to
stop them
and to work with the city and the state
to get the job done local authorities
have to investigate and prosecute all of
these
crimes immediately we'll work with you
and the local authorities know who they
are they know where
they come from they know a lot about
them they ought to
get their act together and get it done
and we're ready to help
if you need that help you shouldn't need
that help actually you should be able to
do it yourselves and get it done very
well again you have excellent
police and law enforcement but you have
to let them do their job
what you're seeing in portland seattle
new york chicago is really the you might
all notice that
this has nothing to do with trump's
agenda for the second term
coronavirus making a case for his
re-election it's it's not it's just
you know dog whistles legislation
gutting and hamstring in every police
department in america
they want to get rid of your second
amendment they want to end cash bail
close prisons well yeah that's the fund
police departments who are at least
largely defunded you see that with new
york a billion dollars they took out of
their police department and crime has
gone through the roof and a point far
left prosecutors who side with the
criminals and target law-abiding
citizens
if the left gains power no city town or
suburb
in our country will be safe
on the vaccine front very good news
today i met with the leaders of
operation warp speed
our historic undertaking to produce a
safe and effective vaccine in record
time
will he mention we heard an update from
top scientists in the government and
the leaders of pharmaceutical companies
which right now aren't uh too thrilled
with me they're taking
millions of dollars worth of ads because
i've created a
favorite nation status for drugs which
is going to reduce
drug prices by 40 50 60 and maybe even
70 percent
you could do the 10 pill routine numbers
that have never been heard ever thought
of
so when you see those ads remember that
means your
drug prices are coming down when you see
ads attacking
your president it's very simple that
means drug prices are going to be
falling very soon
he seems to be on something this evening
i'm pleased to announce that we have
reached an agreement
with modernity to manufacture and
deliver
100 million doses of their coronavirus
vaccine candidate
the federal government will own these
vaccine
doses we're buying them recently we also
secured partnerships with johnson and
johnson
as well as sanofi and gsx to
support the large-scale manufacturing
of their vaccines doing very well in
those vaccines
what about kaiser there's promise in
every single one of them and we have
many of them
and there are years ahead of schedule
this would have been if it were
in the previous administration or any of
the previous administrations where we
are now would have taken years
i'm shocked he hasn't made a deal with
hefsephahide
three vaccine candidates are now in
phase three trials already
the final stage of clinical trials this
is the final stage
we are investing in the development and
manufacture
of the top six vaccine candidates to
ensure rapid delivery
the military is ready to go they're
ready to deliver a vaccine
to americans as soon as one is fully
approved by the fda and we're moving
very close to that approval
we're on track to rapidly produce 100
million doses as soon as the vaccine is
approved and
up to 500 million shortly thereafter
so we'll have 600 million doses
operation warp speed is the largest and
most advanced
operation of its kind anywhere in the
world and anywhere in history
we've treated more than 86 000 americans
with convalescent plasma
a recent mayo clinic study found that
this treatment may produce
oh man results which are incredible we
look
good every time reduction and reduce
mortality rate by 50 percent
and possibly even more than 50 oh man
i urge americans who have recovered from
the virus to go to
coronavirus.gov and sign up
and donate we would really appreciate
that
because it's been very successful
unbelievably successful
please say it once more and we would
love you to go and donate
donate as we continue to confront the
global pandemic the united states
economy is rebounding with strength like
nobody thought possible
you've seen the numbers you see what's
going on yesterday today and
tomorrow my opinion we're very poised
for
a great third quarter and very poised
for some great stock market numbers and
401k numbers and everything else today
the dow jones
passed 28 000 points for the first time
more than a 50
surge since just march so we've
increased by 50 percent
more than since just march it has gained
approximately 9
500 points that same period march
and has recovered nearly all of its
value since the virus struck our nation
think of that
america's economy is incredible
and its economic recovery is outpacing
our peer nations
last quarter the european union's gdp
decline
was nearly 40 percent worse than the
united states so it's 40 percent worse
than the united states we've
built such a strong base that we're able
to do things and
sustain better than anybody in the world
by far
france's gdp decline was nearly 80
percent worse than ours and spain
experienced an economic contraction
twice as severe as the united states
nationwide we continue to see
improvements in our
fight against the pandemic very
substantial improvements
since last week 87 percent
of the counties in the united states
report declining cases
think of that 87 percent of the counties
in
the united states they reported
declining cases
mortality has declined by 7 and
hospitalizations are declining
rapidly states that were primary hot
spots yeah for people wondering this is
live and it is not slowed down this is
normal speed
such as florida texas and arizona have
reduced cases by nearly 25 percent
but all americans must remain vigilant
practice good hygiene
socially distance wear a mask
whenever possible whenever you
are getting too close to people wear a
mask
but the virus continues to increase in
nations across the globe last week
france and germany both recorded their
highest daily number
of new cases in three months
not that i want to bring that up so this
is important all those places are seeing
rising cases but it's a tiny number
compared
per capita compared to the us and
they're immediately putting guidelines
back in place
last week unfortunately and that is
truly unfortunate
it's increased 82 percent in france
113 he's doing percentages because the
numbers are very very small
those are big increases cases
are also rapidly increasing in the
netherlands sweden belgium
switzerland slovakia estonia and other
european countries
visibly struggling and in our country
they're going down
we will be seeing that even more rapidly
as time goes by
short time even though america has the
largest at-risk population including 1.5
million residents of nursing homes
about five times that of other european
countries europe has experienced a
nearly 40 percent higher
excess mortality rate
than the united states we also have
fewer deaths per capita
excluding the disastrous deaths from the
new york tri-state area
you guys see what he did there he's just
saying if we don't count all the deaths
our deaths per capita are low
which had a very very hard time
fascinating and did better than our peer
nations of western europe
thanks to our excellent and highly
advanced medical excluding all the
people that died we have a zero death
toll
care and skill something that the news
doesn't tell you they don't tell you
that they don't like to tell you that
the united states has now conducted more
than
66 million tests far more than any other
nation in the world irrelevant numbers
india which has a
population of 1.5 billion people has
done 20. since when is india the
standard for whether we're doing
something well 24 million so we're at 66
million
and think of it india's at 24 million
and india's second the entire region
of latin america comprising 33 countries
okay so now you're comparing us to 33
countries
has conducted 25 million tests
yet latin america has more confirmed
cases by far than the united states
as we safely those are countries trump
previously referred to as [ __ ]
countries now he's saying hey we're
doing better than them restore a great
economy and reopen our schools and
hopefully
we can watch colleges play football we
want to get football in colleges
these are young strong people they won't
have a big problem
with the china virus
so we want to see college football start
and hopefully a lot of
great people are going to be out there
they're going to be out there playing
football and
they'll be able to fight it off and
hopefully it won't bother them one bit
most of them will never get it
statistically
okay but we know we'll see more cases at
some point and
we will eventually develop sufficient
immunity
in addition to everything else that
we're doing so college football get out
there and play football people want to
see it and stand for your american flag
stanfia national anthem it's hard to
imagine
um a less ideal sport than football to
be playing right now
because people are not happy when that
doesn't happen you look at the nba and
what's happening with the nba and
they're poor nobody is fine no
nba but they didn't stand they didn't
show respect to
our flag respect and show respect to our
our national answers and uh
maybe that's having an impact but i
don't think so
not good the nfl had its problems two
years ago i didn't even think that the
national anthem was televised in
basketball at least it didn't used to be
when that happened they went way down in
their ratings and their fans
and they struggled back and now all of a
sudden they're putting themselves in the
same position so stand for your flag
and stand for the national anthem he's
basically
directing people in terms of what speech
is okay
and i think you're going to do
fantastically well
because a lot of people aren't going to
watch if you don't i'm one of them
that's untrue
that's why our strategy not even on tv
focused on preventing the cases that are
most likely to require
discussing the opening of schools
hospitalization or produce any death
we have to maintain vigilance over our
elderly population
we've learned that i think more than any
single event
scott we have to that's right scott be
very vigilant
all over but we have to really protect
our elderly population and especially
our elderly population that has problems
with
heart lung
any form of of sickness diabetes in
particular
does a number on the lungs and we are at
the same time in very good shape with
respect to
hospital room and hospital overcrowding
we're in great shape
on the nursing home front protecting our
nursing home residents is a critical
focus of our
strategy hhs recently announced
that they will use the provider relief
fund to deliver an additional five
billion dollars to further protect
nursing homes
and long-term care facilities as they
continue to combat the china virus
we have delivered over 1 800 rapid
point-of-care testing devices to nursing
homes
is it weird that like we barely even
react to him calling it the china virus
anymore
15 000 medicare and medicaid certified
nursing homes
by the end of september so they're going
to have very very rapid tests
they won't have to wait around two or
three days or four days and
that number has come down very
substantially
compared to what it was when you send it
to the labs you get a very accurate test
but it takes a period of time to send it
to check it and then to send it back but
we are now at a position well they don't
send the test back they just do results
very very rapid tests five minutes to 15
minutes
we will care for america's seniors as we
develop the vaccine
and therapeutics and therapeutics are
coming along
very very well we think we have some
great answers on therapeutics and you'll
be hearing that
about them in the very near future i'm
very much into
the world of therapeutics where you're
going to the hospital that's this thing
and you give a
shot or you do what you have to do with
it
perhaps transfusion it's complications
of
what you can do and people get better i
like that very much i like that
very very much and that could even
proceed
in a successful in getting it uh that
will i think probably even precede
vaccines
verbal and very very very well
a lot of people are gonna be very happy
when they see
some of the numbers that were that i'm
seeing and some of the results yeah
tremendously people in the hospital once
he shows them numbers we'll be thrilled
but front and uh our country should be
very proud of itself we're going to get
it delivered very rapidly as soon as it
comes out
okay uh questions please
please thank you mr president 20 million
people are due to be evicted from their
homes next month
and are you do you fear that this could
be your herbert hoover move moment
if he doesn't know who that is to reach
a deal with congress to set up a new
care site
we are not allowing that to happen we're
stopping evictions
we are stopping evictions we're not
going to let that happen also we're not
going to evict people we're not going to
let people
the democrats maybe they don't care but
i care
and we signed an executive offer you
know uh
executive order you know that right
sure and uh we are not telling people be
evicted
thank you thank you president trump if i
could have two questions i'd like to ask
you one about senator harris's record
and then a different one about visa
abuse sure um so
regarding uh senator harris's record you
had a pretty uh
quick response to that you had an ad out
that said that she was a phony
and i wanted to drill down she was a
what
he doesn't even know and i wanted to ask
about a specific example that a lot of
people thought was a phony moment
um as san francisco d.a she oversaw
according to the mercury news 1900
marijuana convictions
but she was asked in an interview last
year if she had smoked marijuana
and she appeared to joke and according
to some people lie and say that she was
listening to snoop dogg and tupac
well their music hadn't come out at the
time trump is a smoking pop
listening why would she lie about that
do you see that as more evidence that
is surpassed on marijuana a liability
well she lied i mean she said things
that were untrue
she is a person that's
told many many stories that weren't true
she's very big into raising taxes sort
of like trump she wants to
slash funds for our military at a level
that nobody's
can even believe she
is against fracking fracking is that's
good fracking
against petroleum products beautiful how
do you do that and go into pennsylvania
or
ohio or oklahoma or the great state of
texas
he's against uh fracking fracking's a
big deal she mentioned that twice now
she's in favor of socialized medicine
where you're going to lose your doctors
you're going to
lose your plan she wants to take your
healthcare plans away from
180 million americans
that's a lot 180 million americans that
are very happy with their
health remember with biden's plan about
35 million more people get health care
insurance and she wants to take that
away
and by the way she's not even for a
single payer is she is kamal i don't
think kamal is for single-payer
so she was my number one pick i mean she
was i as they would say because
hopefully you'll start college football
she was my number one
draft pick and we'll see how she works
out
she did very very poorly in the uh
primaries as you know she was expected
to do well
and she was she ended up at
right around two percent and spent a lot
of money
she had a lot of things happening and so
i was a little surprised that he picked
her
i've been watching her for a long time
and i was a little surprised she was
extraordinarily nasty to
kavanaugh judge kavanaugh then now
justice
she was brilliant with kavanaugh
actually that's why i think she'll crush
pence
she was nasty to a level that was just
a horrible thing the way she was the way
she treated
now justice the way she treated
kavanaugh is the one thing that
it actually is a saving grace in my mind
kavanagh
and i won't forget that soon so she did
very poorly in the primaries and now
she's chosen so let's see how that all
works
there's a marijuana legalization vote
for you rather than her because she
convicted so many people in the past
uh i can't tell you what she's voting
for i don't think she knows what i think
joe knows even less than she does but i
was only surprised at the pick a lot of
people would say that might be the pick
i was more surprised than anything else
because she did so poorly many people
did much better
by definition the person who gets chosen
unless they weren't in the primary at
all
did less well than the person who
becomes the nominee obviously her in the
primary
she did very poorly in the primaries and
that's like a poll
you know that's like a poll i also asked
you about bison thieves
president trump um yes about bison abuse
um so now it's widely accepted among
republicans there was fisa abuse
tremendous violence the justice
department ig
has found that with carter page board
application but uh we were actually
warned in 2013 that the surveillance
court was allegedly a rubber stamp
it was approving surveillance and i was
wondering i don't think as president
you've commented on edward snowden but
do you think you should be allowed to
return
without going to prison so as far as
fisa abuse is concerned there was
tremendous visor abuse
amazing that it's taken this long and
everyone knows that it's been
proven very substantially abuse
changing documents and putting documents
in front of
the fisa court and courts that are
disgraceful that they could have done it
and the fact is we caught
joe biden president obama the whole
group
you can look at brennan and comey and
clapper
the whole group we caught him spying on
our campaign this was an illegal act
like no other illegal act this was true
biggest crime
treason was at the highest level of
treason hang him up
and obama and biden got caught
spying on my camera none of this is
using intelligence agencies of
the united states government to do it
both before
and after the election so before the
election then after i won
they continued it's totally illegal
activity and now we just have to see
what's happening but as far as
kamala is concerned he's a big tax
raiser she's a big
slasher of funds for our military and
she's
got a lot of difficult things isn't
kamala the drug in battle star galactica
things that she's going to have to
explain plus she was very very nasty
to one of the reasons that surprised me
she was very
she was probably nastier than even
pocahontas
to joe biden she was very disrespectful
to joe biden
that's xenophobia and it's hard to pick
somebody that's that disrespectful when
she said things during the debates
during the
democrat primary debates that were
horrible about
sleepy joe and uh i would think that he
wouldn't have picked
oan please oh thank you
yesterday seattle city council voted to
cut funding for their police department
and
the chief the police chief there carmen
best
the first black woman to serve in that
capacity she resigned hours later what
does this say about our country what
does this say about the
police movement well i think that
seattle
in spite of all that they've been
through with the embarrassment of having
a
radical left group antifa and others
take over a big portion of
the city of seattle we're talking about
a big city a major city
right that they allowed that to happen
is incredible that it took so long to
fix is incredible the only reason they
went in is because they knew
we were going in the following day and
so they
preceded us they didn't want that to
happen they didn't want to be
embarrassed
and the people just gave up they weren't
they were exhausted from
having taken over a city for so long
the police commissioner seems like a
very good woman
they were going to slash her salary by
40 or 50 percent
and they cut a tremendous amount off the
police department
really where people are saying it's not
sustainable as a good police department
and again those police are good also
but they're not allowed to do their job
i hate to see her go because she did in
her own way a very good job but
she wasn't effective in convincing
the mayor and the city council to give
the funds that were needed
or just leave the funds the way they are
they've done a big
a big defund a big part of
and it will probably get worse before
people realize this is a tragic era
before people start dying
and getting hurt very badly so i think
seattle's made a
tragic mistake i think portland uh
has no clue as to what they're doing
they have no clue
and hopefully they'll be asking for help
because we can solve their problem
very very quickly yeah go ahead thank
you sir mr president uh
two questions one on uh senator harris
very simply is she going to help but uh
former vice president biden's chances in
november or is he record
well i like vice president mike pence
much better
he is solid as a rock he's been a
fantastic
vice president he's going to get crushed
in debates
he's respected by every religious group
whether it's evangelical
whether it's any other group they
respect mike pence
he's been a great vice president the
buddhist community loves him i will take
him over
kamala and the horrible way she again
treated
justice kavanaugh that was a horrible
event i thought it was terrible for her
i thought it was terrible for our nation
i thought she was
the meanest
the the most horrible most disrespectful
of anybody in the
u.s senate she's also known
from what i understand as being just
about the most liberal person in the u.s
senate and i would have thought that
biden would have tried this okay
so obviously she wasn't even the most
liberal senator running this year
obviously bernie is to her left and
warren is to her left this is just
idiocy
away from that a little bit because with
what they're doing with open borders and
sanctuary cities where they're trying to
protect sanctuary cities which is also
protecting large number of criminals
with all of the things that they're
doing second amendment
they want to take away your second
amendment or modify it to a point where
it's essentially no longer the second
amendment does anyone believe this
critical in a different way
thank you very much everybody
donald trump cutting it uh very very
short today
as you can see um kind of a weird low
energy trump yeah yeah definitely a lot
of people picking up on the the extreme
low energy from the president there
um okay well listen i mean we didn't get
we didn't get a lot there um not exactly
clear what he's thinking
from the standpoint of kamala or
kamala depending on your predilection
um but tomorrow on the program i'm going
to have full coverage of the kamala
harris
selection for vice president you can go
back to the beginning of this stream
if you want to see my initial thoughts
about that
we are make no mistake we are in the
middle
of a huge battle to get to 1
million subscribers before sam cedar if
you're heading out on youtube there's 22
000 of you right now hit that subscribe
button on the way out we're at 933
000 right now if just a few of you hit
subscribe
we could get to 9 40 like that okay
little a little humid so my snapping is
not quite so good today
um but please do help us in that battle
uh if you are watching on twitch
remember to hit that follow button
because uh
you guys matter very much as well and
always remember you can send me memes
clips and other stuff you want me to
review on stream
through the contact form at
davidpakman.com
and of course of course of course do not
forget
the number one way to support all of the
work that we do here the staff everybody
is to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
i'll see everybody tomorrow thanks for
joining me
race to a million against sam cedar it's
happening right now
you